there are of course those who do not
want us to speak it has to stop
the federal government
has invoked the emergencies act the
police will be given more tools to
restore order and where once you had the
freedom to object to think and speak as
you saw fit you now have sensors and
systems of surveillance coercing your
conformity these changes cover all forms
of transactions
including digital assets there were a
myriad of problems which conspired to
corrupt your reason and rob you of your
common sense
fear got the best of you the
consequences are becoming more and more
severe and in your panic you turn to the
now high chancellor he promised you
order he promised you peace and all he
demanded in return was your silent
obedient consent and if you're still
participating
the time to go home
is now fairness justice and freedom are
more than words
they are perspectives
so if you've seen nothing if the crimes
of this government remain unknown to you
but if you see what i see
if you feel as i feel
and if you would seek as i seek and
remember people should not be afraid of
their governments
government should be afraid
[Music]
chill down my spine people and we put it
together ourselves yeah there's a little
cold open for you
as we call it in the biz i had that idea
last night from that incredible speech
obviously from the movie v for vendetta
which if you have not seen you must see
it we've done it as a reuben report
locals community movie night uh where we
watch some movies together and we can
chat during the films
that's an extraordinary speech right at
the top of the movie it's about a
three-minute speech we spliced it
together i had this idea yesterday to
put some uh justin trudeau's nonsense
and what's going on in canada to lay it
in with that speech
shout out to my man conor who put that
thing together for us uh we will be
clipping that separately and getting it
up on social media and i'm gonna play it
again at the end of the show today
because
i'm sure people will want to see that
again and uh
chilling right chilling yeah so there
you go uh it is february 17th 2022 we
are live streaming on rumble youtube
emblaze tv do me a favor share subscribe
tap notification bells all of that good
stuff
and uh the letter of the day everybody
is f
okay it's f
not for that but for fascism because
fascism's on the move it really is on
the move i mean it's it's one of the
overused
terms one of the overused words that we
hear all the time nazi
bigot racist islamophobe fascist
but actual fascism is coming okay it
really is on the march particularly in
canada but not just in canada and over
the course of the next half hour we're
going to lay out quite a case so we are
going with another one of these
narrative shows which seem to be uh seem
to be taken over at the moment there's
an authoritarian move to have me do more
narrative shows and that's what we're
doing so we're going to talk about
left-wing fascism today and how it's
sort of permeating throughout the entire
system right now whether it comes to
masks or tech or what's going on in
canada and attacking people's bank
accounts and stopping people from being
able to protest and more it's messy uh
but we're gonna try to do it with uh
with some fun stuff in there too
and uh i think you're gonna dig the show
today but before we get to all of that i
want to talk to oh no before i get to
three day blinds i saw this comment
yesterday and i was like you know i see
comments when i can when i have moments
i usually just look at the the locals
community that's where i interact with
people throughout the day and i always
respond to people in there but every now
and again i jump into some of the other
things just to sort of get a feeling
like a little just taste of what's going
on and i saw this comment on youtube
yesterday and i was like i actually have
to read it i have to read it to the
people because it's so perfect it's it's
so chef's kiss
perfect that i was like i have to i have
to read it so here we go i can't believe
i'm at this point but i am could you
please stop including clips of cnn or at
least provide time codes so we can
easily skip them i am not going to
subject myself to that vile
reprehensible double speak i'm about
done from here on out if cnn shows up
i'm out for that video i'll keep trying
because you're worth supporting but i
just can't take any more of cnn's crap
i thought that that was just so perfect
because cnn has gotten so bad
it's such a factory
of nonsense
that they are not only harming their own
ratings but they're actually harming
other people's ratings for talking about
them there must be a german word for
that right shouting viewer or something
there's there's got to be something well
good person who wrote that comment i can
tell you truly we have no cnn videos for
you today i will warn you we have some
videos from crazy college kids we have
videos from wannabe hitler justin
trudeau couple other people but there is
nothing
directly from cnn okay before we get to
all that i want to talk to you guys
about three day blinds you know are
vaccine mandates and rising crime rates
making you want to shut out the world
would make sense well you're probably
not alone and i have the solution for
you three-day blinds they are the
leading manufacturer and retailer of
custom window treatments in the u.s and
right now they're running a buy one get
one fifty percent off deal three-day
blinds brings the showroom to you their
local professionally trained trained
designed consultants provide expert
advice in the comfort of your own home
just set up an appointment and they'll
get you a free quote the same day their
team handles all the heavy lifting they
design measure and install so you can
sit back and relax no matter your unique
need from motorization and home
automation to room darkening and child
safety three day blinds has a window
treatment for you choose from thousands
of options that fit any budget or style
and with actual samples that means no
guessing on what your blinds will look
like and no joke we had three day blinds
people here yesterday and we're getting
automated shades we got a lot to do with
the new house and i'm looking forward to
it
a clever feature i love is that you can
preset the time for your shades to open
or close each day we're going to be
doing that three day blinds has been in
business for over 40 years and has
thousands of five star reviews so they
are a trusted brand right now you can
get three day blinds buy one get one 50
off deal on custom blinds shades and
drapery for free for a free no charge
obligation consultation head over to
threedayblinds.com
reuben and use my code ruben that's
right buy one get one for 50 off when
you head over to 3dayblinds.com ruben
and use my promo code ruben one last
time that's three the number three
daveblinds.comruben and now back to me
okay
you know i've had a policy here that
we've tried to do a little less
on covid directly unless there's good
news so good news would be you say i
don't know a grassroots group of people
say in canada that are coming together
to fight the government because they
want to go back to work and go back to
school and don't want the government to
force them to be injected with an
experimental vaccine or they don't want
their kids to be in masks forever that
would be a good thing and we've covered
a lot of that the people taking the
power back uh but every now and again
something happens and it's like well we
should cover this because it's so
it's so important in the story of covid
that we've just all been
traversing through let's say in the last
two years so i haven't talked much about
fauci in a week or so but lord fauci the
infallible fouchy the man who has
basically gotten everything wrong from
beat one who i'm pretty sure lied under
oath when rand paul asked him about gain
of function research
you remember that from about two months
ago
who was telling people that they should
be double masking while in private
emails was telling people masks don't
work who lied about the efficacy of the
vaccines who seemingly every day changes
his policies on everything who very
rarely as i always note very rarely
actually gives you numbers related to
policy he always says well when we get
rates low enough but never tells you
what that rate is never mentions
anything like herd immunity doesn't talk
about two weeks to flatten the curve
anymore yada yada i think you guys get
it well now he's still
he's still after two years later with
all of this [ __ ]
he's still thinking that uh
masks on planes are good let me ask you
about spaces that are under federal
jurisdiction i'm thinking of planes for
example i believe that mass mandate is
set to expire the middle of the next
month
what recommendation do you anticipate
making to president biden when it comes
time to either extend that mandate or
close it out where do you think we are
you know hallie i don't want to get
ahead of the decision-making process
because a lot of it is going to depend
on what i mentioned
just a moment ago
namely the trajectory of that downward
dynamic because if things start
plateauing and going up which i i don't
think they will i hope they won't but we
want to make sure that when we make a
decision it's based on the science as we
see it at that time and it continues to
change fortunately fortunately for us
it's going in the right direction right
now and i think when the time comes for
any kind of a policy decision to be made
it will be based on the data as it is so
why don't we just hold off before we
make any predictions about that
how about no
how about no fouchy how about we don't
have to listen to you anymore how about
if you get on a plane and you'd like to
wear a mask and you'd like to wear a
face shield and you'd like to wrap your
body
in tin foil and you'd like to wrap your
head in saran wrap that you can do it
it's up to you and if you'd like to
subject the people in your family to
that you can do that too but how about
everyone else gets to make a choice for
themselves now of course he doesn't give
the numbers again what he talks about is
the downward trajectory that we're on
right now and we wouldn't want it to
bump up but doesn't give you the numbers
related to all that uh he has never once
never once and please internet sleuths
prove me wrong
talked about how many people have
actually gotten or transmitted covid
while on planes as a matter of fact
every time you get on a plane they show
you a video about how safe planes are
they talk about how they're 99.9999
uh air purifiers get rid of all the
germs and that air in planes is cleaner
than regular air and they're filtering
the hell out of that air and then they
show you that video with a guy who looks
like he's from ghostbusters wearing a
mask going through the plane with his
green gun spraying all sorts of stuff
which they don't really do it's just
they do it for that video so that you
feel good about it
that of course is right before they tell
you how to use a seat belt in case
you're a complete idiot
i think you get the point guys he's
never gonna stop he he is a power
hungry lunatic at this point and
my goal i i said it as a joke uh right
when we got to florida but i really mean
it at this point we we flew private i've
only flown private twice in my entire
life um and it's it's obviously a
it's a beautiful thing if you can figure
out how to do it i had a friend i have a
friend who uh who's got some good
financial means and when we were moving
from cali
to florida we didn't want to put clyde
the dog under the plane because you know
there's always that risk and the
air quality down there and it gets cold
and all sorts of stuff so i asked my
friend could you could you help us out
and get us over to florida in your
private plan which he did help us out
and we're very appreciative of that but
when we landed here i thought you know
my goal now
is to get so rich that i never have to
fly a commercial again because
commercial is a miserable experience i
don't mean that like i need to be so
rich so i can you know throw faberge
eggs off the roof
but they have made everything i mean
it's such a continuation of everything
else they've made flying miserable
they've made going to stores miserable
going to restaurants put on the mask
while you're walking to the thing then
take off the mask and say they've just
tried to destroy everything and do you
sense any remorse in fouchy and again i
keep saying it but why has no one been
fired no one has been fired this entire
time has anyone at the cdc been fired
has anyone at any of these organizations
the nih any of these places been fired
has anyone been reprimanded has anyone
been treated like whoopi goldberg and
said you can't come to work for two
weeks but we'll still pay you
i don't think so very very very weird
but we've got a lot more fascism coming
because this is what fascists do they
try to take over your life usually
through the government but also in their
connections through corporations and
everything else and we got we got plenty
of that uh but let me talk to you guys
about helix sleep before we get to that
you know i just received my helix
mattress there's something good when
you're a podcaster and you move into a
new house because you get blinds you get
mattresses a whole bunch more this thing
is super soft uh helix sleep has a quiz
that takes just two minutes to complete
i did it myself and then it matches your
body type and the sl and your sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you why buy a mattress made for someone
else with helix you're getting a
mattress a mattress that'll be perfect
for the way you sleep helix knows that
everybody's unique so they offer several
different mattress models they have soft
medium and firm mattresses
i need some coffee we should have a
coffee sponsor
and the mattresses are great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot the mattresses
are great for spinal alignment to
prevent morning aches and pains and even
a helix plus for plus size sleepers when
i took the quiz i was matched with the
midnight luxe mattress because it's
great for side sleepers which i am and
i've got it right downstairs and i'm
loving this thing so if you're looking
for a mattress take the quiz order your
perfect match and the mattress ships
right to your door for free you don't
ever need to go to a mattress store
again helix has been recommended by
leading chiropractors and doctors of
sleep medicine as a solution for
improving sleep just go to helix
sleep.com reuben take their two-minute
sleep quiz and they'll match you with a
customized mattress that'll give you the
best sleep of your life they have a 10
year warranty and you'll get to try it
out for 100 nights risk free helix even
has financing options and
flexible payment plans so a great
night's sleep is never far away helix is
offering up to hundred dollars off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helixsleep.com
reuben check it out guys and now back to
me all right so let's talk about the
next level of fascism because i think
when people think of fascism it's sort
of it's sort of this like amorphous
thing is it is it government is it
corporations is it corporations and
government all of these forces that are
conspiring to control us at every level
and we're seeing it happen sort of right
in front of our eyes right now so you've
got you know guys like fauci who two
years later are still pulling all of the
levers of government to tell you what
you should wear on your face when you
travel but it's not just government
people right it's not just you know say
biden and fouchy and governors and
congress people it's also leaders of
corporations who are deciding what we
are allowed to say when we can say it
who can hear what you say etc etc so
there was a really interesting video
uh that was going viral yesterday of
youtube's youtube ceo susan wajesky i
believe that's the pronunciation of her
last name and she's actually calling
for more worldwide government censorship
to make her job as youtube ceo easier
take a look uh well first of all i'll
say that for uh you know we we work
around the globe and you're right
certainly there are many different laws
in many different
jurisdictions and we
um we enforce the laws of the various
jurisdictions around
speech or what's considered safe or not
safe that actually hasn't been the
controversial part what has been the
controversial part has been when there
is content that would be deemed as
harmful but yet is not illegal
um so an example of that for example
would be kovid i'm not aware of there
being
laws by government saying around coven
in terms of not being able to debate the
efficacy
of masks or where the virus came from or
the right treatment or proposal but yet
there was a lot of pressure and concern
about us
distributing misinformation that went
against what was considered the standard
and accepted medical knowledge you know
our recommendation if governments want
to have more control over online speech
is to to pass laws to have that be very
cleanly and clearly defined such that we
can implement it
do i even have to comment on this do you
see what she did right there at the end
now we can all debate
how we can effectively communicate true
information
we all talk about science changing
you've heard of this fellow joe rogan he
has a very scary podcast where he puts
on
scientists who sometimes question the
official narrative put on this crazy guy
robert malone one of the guys who has
the most
patents related to mrna technology but
somehow that was too dangerous to get
out there and he got in some trouble
with spotify i don't have to go down
that road again but what she said there
at the end our recommendation our
recommendation you are the youtube ceo
our recommendation youtube as the
premier platform in the world to get
video out
many of you most of you are watching
this on youtube right now although i
wish you'd be watching on rumble and
we're going to keep pushing you to
rumpel and rumble is the future uh but a
lot of you are watching this on youtube
right now youtube is the ubiquitous
video platform obviously okay youtube is
actually also people don't know this
it's also the second largest search
engine online meaning google itself is
the number one search engine youtube is
the number two search engine it's a
search engine in effect for video but
it's the number two search engine
overall she is calling
for governments to pass more laws so
that she can restrict speech further
because she knows she can't really do it
on her own because it gets too messy
people get upset and it's like wait a
minute you're an american company why
are you suppressing free speech then we
can get into all the debates about the
first amendment
and of course that you know youtube is
supposedly a private company but are
they working with governments all of
that stuff but the idea that the ceo of
youtube would basically say to
governments worldwide i mean look what's
happening in canada right now so she's
begging now justin trudeau who is
encroaching on his people's freedoms
she's basically saying hey trudeau
liberals you guys are in charge uh
we'd love to help you out but it would
be a little messy if we did it you know
i've got a board it's tough to do stuff
but if you just pass the law to make it
that nobody could say criticize you
justin uh yeah we could we could do what
we could yeah we'll we'll help you out i
mean think about the craziness of this
are you going to encourage
susan i'll talk directly to you we've
met once remember we had that off the
meeting
off the record meeting at youtube you
didn't want to take a selfie with me you
take a lot of selfies with other
creators when they go visit but with me
there was a pr person there and it was
very clear that you didn't really want
me there and okay that's fine um
but susan uh i don't think you should be
encouraging governments
to suppress speech because you know in
certain places in the world they treat
say gay people
badly would you want them to pass laws
so that they could not allow gay people
to speak or laws that would stifle their
speech etc etc or other minorities
religious minorities trans people uh
because i'm pretty sure there's some
countries that don't love trans people
would would you want the government if
the governments of those places pass
laws saying you can't say anything nice
about trans people uh what are we gonna
do about that and of course this you can
obviously you guys see where i'm going
with this you extend this to why wokism
just destroys everything because now
you've got a ceo of an
unbelievably powerful company like
google youtube like extraordinary power
unimaginable power our founders could
have never imagined something that could
have this much more power than the
government and that's what google has uh
they are begging governments to do their
job for them
this is a huge problem this is a huge
problem and if you don't think it's a
problem well just yesterday
defiant elves which is a huge huge
twitter account what they do on twitter
they had about 350 000 followers all
they do basically
are take screenshots
of tweets from lefties liberals whatever
you want to call them who are now wrong
in their predictions or what they have
said over the years well their account
got blown up yesterday it is now
suspended deleted it's gone it ain't
going to come back it doesn't matter
what kind of pressure is brought to bear
it ain't coming back and why did it
get blown up well first off as i said
all that the account does all that the
account does is take screenshots to
expose hypocrisy that's all it does so
it's mirroring what other people are
saying that's it so if you were going to
suspend people you'd think you'd maybe
suspend the people with the original
information but it's not about that
they're exposing the hypocrisy they're
doing it quite well this is their last
tweet and i think perhaps guys you're
going to see how they got away with it
here so the first tweet that you're
seeing up there
uh do i have the text guys
wait one second do i have the text oh
there we go uh the first tweet that we
have up there is justin trudeau
from uh 2012
and he's quoting in this tweet he's
quoting stephen harper in 2005. stephen
harper was the canadian prime minister
at that time and he says when a
government starts trying to cancel
dissent or avoid dissent is when it's
rapidly losing its moral authority to
govern so he's quoting stephen harper
saying that in 2005 because stephen
harper was was prime minister in 2012 so
he's trying to show trudeau trying to
show that harper is a bad dude right but
of course you all know that's exactly
what trudeau is doing now so defiant
else took that to eat and then he linked
it with this one
just trudeau from a day or two ago the
ongoing blockades and occupations are
presenting serious challenges to law
enforcement's ability to effectively
enforce the law because of that the
federal government is invoking the
emergencies act to supplement provincial
and territorial capacity so all
defianelles did was take one trudeau
tweet
show it with another trudeau tweet
and they got blown up on twitter so when
i show you that
and again they didn't edit them there
was no misinformation it's literally
just quoting
what the prime minister of canada is
saying when i show you that coupled with
the youtube ceo saying oh
governments could you could you do
something around speech so that we
don't have to do our work uh you see we
got a problem here we got a real problem
here and by the way this is not a new
idea for this justin true trudeau guy
this video was going around yesterday
this is a couple years ago this is
trudeau talking about the country that
he admires most even with sun tv
watching for any slip he was asked which
country he most admired and referred to
china there's a level of uh admiration i
actually have for china
um because their
basic dictatorship is allowing them
uh to actually turn their economy around
on a dime and say we need to go green as
fast as we need to start you know
investing in solar
ah it's so beautiful it's so beautiful
when they tell you exactly what they are
and that's exactly what he did there
i come in with rainbows and unicorns
intolerance and love and
lgbtqi what are all the other letters
you've all seen the video
but who does he really admire when push
comes to shove he really admires china
and why does he admire china because
china doesn't give a flying f about
their citizens individual rights china
is a collectivist society so you know
what happens in a collectivist society
where everyone basically has to bow to
the government the government can get a
lot done and that's what trudeau is
saying there's a lot of things that i
want to get done and you know what you
got to crush when you're trying to get a
lot done you have to crush the
individual and that's what this all
boils down to the individual versus the
state and trudeau at some level is not
really a person and what i mean by that
i don't mean it to dehumanize him i mean
it in that he just represents something
a government a conglomerate a
corporation a worldwide whatever that's
what trudeau is as a person that's why
he reeks of inauthenticity right that's
why
you know that everything he's saying is
a lie that nothing is is truly
passionate or decent that comes out of
him right because he doesn't represent
himself he represents an idea a bad idea
so you got to crush all the individuals
along the way so what he's saying there
is i do
i dig china because they can get [ __ ]
done so i come in i sound like a nice
guy but really what i am is an awful
authoritarian uh
we can just put that right next to this
video from yesterday about uh compelling
people to do what he wants
in windsor
we relied on
generous partnership with the americans
to be able to get tow trucks to move the
big trucks
now with these
measures that we've put in place
there will be an ability to compel
for just compensation
tow truck owners and operators to
actually do the jobs for which they have
contracts with various orders of
government to keep highways and roads
clear
they're going to compel
them to do that stuff that's how they're
going to compel them how do you think
they're going to compel them they're
going to pay you know they're going to
take other people's money
that they pay in taxes to compel them to
do things that perhaps they don't want
to do and then you might say to the
people hey if you don't do the stuff
that we're compelling you to do we might
actually shut your bank accounts i mean
this is a bad dude
bad dude uh and what's interesting about
this is as i said they always come in
with this rainbow thing they come in
with the diversity thing they're the
good guys and then very quickly and that
is the silver lining here guys right
like we're they're being unmasked right
in front of us right that's why all the
progressives in america right now and
all our news networks are either
ignoring this or
obfuscating what's really going on i'll
get more on that in just a second
because it's their people that are now
being shown to be the worst right if
this was if trudeau was saying these
very things and he was a leader say in
the arab world in the middle east and he
was saying hey if you go against me and
protest me we're not gonna let you have
bank accounts um we're gonna compel
people to do certain things right uh
we'd have biden out there going you know
well maybe we should invade there should
be some sort of invasion we should you
know be encouraging but we've been
through this before look what happened
in egypt with hosni mubarak who was the
dictator there for 30 years and then
obama after two days of protest obama
was like yeah we're done with that guy
but look how we operate a little bit
differently when it's uh justin trudeau
up in canada but one of the things that
they come in with is this diversity all
this faux
you know tolerance stuff but what they
love is the idea of unity right they're
always talking about unity we should be
united
they don't mean it what they mean is
that half the people should just bow
uh but trudeau because he needs unity he
needs the idea of unity he's now telling
the canadian people that what's
happening right now it's not even
dividing canadians it's all good
um
it has been clear that this is something
that democracies around the world are
concerned with
countries that did well during the
pandemic with high vaccination rates and
strong public health measures
are still seeing
backlashes against those measures
and
frustration by people who are tired of
this pandemic and the
impact of
social media and
illicit funding
of
concerted activities designed to
destabilize a country that has the
highest vaccination rate of many of our
peer countries canada
around an issue that is not dividing
canadians canadians are united in having
been there for each other through this
pandemic and they're even united and
being sick and tired of this pandemic
but the way to get through it
is not to shut down our economy and hurt
our neighbors
remember i said a week ago or so that
when i did the show here in miami with
jordan peterson about two weeks ago that
there was a question about justin
trudeau that was asked by the audience
and uh jordan said that justin trudeau
is simply incapable of saying a true
statement and you really can feel it
right there because he needs unity right
because he loves they love this idea of
conformity and collectivism and what
that would mean is that there would be
no dissenting voices right because they
know what's good for you so the the lie
there is just incredible as he is
literally passing emergency powers to
stifle dissent in his supposed free
country
as he's doing that telling people that
their bank accounts will be shut down
that they will be arrested if they're
out on the streets and god only knows
what they're doing behind the scenes
he's telling you that they're united
they're united and at the same time
everybody loves what we've done here
everybody loves the masks everybody
loves the mandates they love me look at
my hair they gotta love me i'm justin
trudeau
it's so bananas ridiculous they lie
about everything and then i saw this uh
conor let's pull this up rasmussen
reports had a new study that 59 of us
voters support canadian truckers in the
freedom convoy protest the reason i
thought this was interesting is because
this story as i've mentioned is
basically being ignored or lied about on
mainstream media so we've shown you some
clips from cnn don't worry guy we're not
going to do it right now we're not
showing the cnn clips but we've showed
you some clips of cnn and msnbc and a
bunch of other news networks where
they're basically calling all of the
protesters racists and their bigots and
you know their anti-vaxxers and a whole
bunch of other nonsense and they're
they're calling them violent and all of
the stuff
so the fact that basically 60
of americans on a rasmussen pole i mean
rasmussen is a pretty reputable pole
pollster the fact that 60 of americans
are with them
is incredible and it also shows you that
the machine is breaking down the
[ __ ] of the machine is not being
it's not working for people anymore so
yesterday i thought you know could could
these people really be as bad i said but
dave give the devil as do
it can't be that
sure every day you make fun of cnn and
you make fun of msnbc but they can't be
as bad as you think surely
surely these journalists these beacons
of freedom
people like jake tapper and brian
stelter they can't be as bad as you
think dave go to their twitter feeds and
look at their twitter feeds and see how
many times they tweeted about the canada
situation yesterday so this is exactly
what i did at 10 pm last night i paused
seinfeld it popped in my head i was
watching
i think it was season three episode two
okay and i popped in my head dave do
this give them their due so that you can
go on the show tomorrow and say hey have
a little mea culpa you know i'm critical
of these guys but they're pretty good
actually well i went on jake tapper's
twitter feed tapper tweeted about 20 30
times yesterday he had zero tweets about
canada
zero tweets about canada he did have a
story about trump at least one story
about trump then i went over to mr
potato head brian stelter's feet over
there zero
uh tweets about canada nothing about
trudeau nothing about canada did have
some stuff about trump and then mostly
his last eight tweets were all about
internal disarray at cnn so that was
kind of fun
um
these people
are not journalists they are activists
they are simply not journalists we don't
even need to throw to my tweet about i
tweeted about it which caught fire
because it's just absolutely insane they
are still obsessed with trump
while this is happening right now so
then uh i saw this last night and i
thought this might be a nice way to
start wrapping up the show today uh you
know these truckers who are being
treated so horribly and and again with
the suspension of bank accounts they're
being called the worst things they're
they are doing their best
to to peacefully fight for their freedom
against all odds they are an inspiration
the world over which is why these uh
rallies are starting in all sorts of
countries across the globe okay these
people these are good decent people
okay and i saw this video last night
this is just a random trucker asked out
who's out on the street just asked about
what's going on take a look all right so
what are your thoughts on trudeau
invoking the emergencies act
absolutely ridiculous
to put something like that on a peaceful
protest is just the same
yeah
are you concerned at all about uh your
bank account
uh no
there's nothing in it anyways
so if he wants to go in there and put
some money in for me that'd be fantastic
how long do you plan on staying in
ottawa
as long as it takes to get this stuff
straightened up absolutely it might
we're not i'm not moving i'm not moving
do you think uh the protest is having an
impact
a huge impact absolutely it's bringing
people together
in huge amounts
man that is a good decent man the way he
laughed he wants to throw some money
into my bank account if anyone can get a
hold of that guy i'll gladly help him
however i can so if you if you can get a
hold of him i know we've got a lot of
truckers and their supporters and other
canadians out there if you if you know
who this guy is please do reach out to
us and let us know and i'm gonna see
what i can do for that guy happy to have
him on the show or help out however i
can that is a good decent man right
there that is not someone who is out
there because he's a bigot or a racist
or anything else that is someone who was
pushed far enough who doesn't have that
much and he was pushed far enough to say
i'll be out here as long as i can in the
freezing cold fighting my government
because they are coming for everything
that i hold dear
and i think it's our duty i actually
think it's our duty to have to stand
with these people and i will continue to
stand with them uh guys you can play
along as always at
reubenreport.locals.com
part two of my interview with charlie
kirk is up right now on youtube and
rumble the full thing's up on locals and
i thought a nice way to end the show
today we started with that v for
vendetta a piece that we put together
we are going to clip it and put it on
social media as well but i thought it
would be nice if we threw it right at
the end
there are of course those who do not
want us to speak it has to stop
the federal government
has invoked the emergencies act the
police will be given more tools to
restore order and where once you have
the freedom to object to think and speak
as you saw fit you now have sensors and
systems of surveillance coercing your
conformity these changes cover all forms
of transactions
including digital assets there were a
myriad of problems which conspired to
corrupt your reason and rob you of your
common sense
fear got the best of you the
consequences are becoming more and more
severe and in your panic you turn to the
now high chancellor
he promised you order he promised you
peace
and all he demanded in return was your
silent obedient consent and if you're
still participating
the time to go home
is now fairness justice and freedom are
more than
are
words
so if you've seen nothing if the crimes
of this government remain unknown to you
but if you see what i see
if you feel as i feel
and if you would seek as i seek and
remember people should not be afraid of
their governments
government should be afraid
[Music]